that's what that is for sushi eaters I
soldier was it was a guy that went
through a claw yeah yeah I saw that like
if he misses he's dead
it's the dead death there's a lot of
videos of those guys dying yeah there
was a video of a guy hitting a bridge
going like 100-plus miles an hour hit
this bridge it was awful I mean [ __ ] off
Wow
yeah bungee jumping on you know Will
Smith is bungee jumping did you see this
video
Will Smith he he posted a video on his
Instagram another guy that has a great
Instagram posted a video about how fear
I know
amazing things are right on the other
side of fear yeah so he's been doing
this thing where he's just conquering
all the spheres and he has a group of
guys that they're professional bungee
jumpers they're bungee jumping on his
birthday his 50th birthday out of a
helicopter over the Grand Canyon
Jesus yeah
this I got to see that seems like a
terrible idea we did a bunch of that
kind of [ __ ] on fear factor man we did
it in the last season in the last season
we did a couple of them that really had
me freaked out but one of them they
hooked people up to these bungee cords
and they were had them tied to like a
post or something or a tree or something
I forget what it was they were shackled
this thing was a post and the person had
to release them well I figure out which
key goes into which lock and it was like
a race to do it and as soon as you
released um they shot through the air
because there was a helicopter holding
onto a bungee cord behind him Wow and
then they were just dangling over this
canyon like bouncing up and down and I
watched the first one like they did a
test one and I watched and I was like
yeah I mean they know what they're doing
I guess they know what they're doing
these guys are like professional stunt
guys but I was like I would not want to
be that person attached to that bungee
cord who was the person that came up
with these things like I would watch the
show I didn't mind the dangerous stuff
like that just the eating like every
time I'm like how did you know you could
eat that yeah they had a whole team you
know that won't kill you they know they
would do toxicology examinations on
certain bugs that grind them up and find
out what you know what
what's bad for you what's not who's that
guy a lot of those people ate food man
that they should know how to eat like
they would do it with interns poor
interns nice kids too hard for like well
they would you know they were working on
production or they're not interns I'm
sorry they were pas production
assistants and they would have to you
know do like these really [ __ ]
difficult eating challenges if they did
it they'd win a certain amount of money
did get a certain amount money I always
give them whatever I had in my pocket to
they won't need anything other than a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich oh this
poor kids like the yeah I was just some
of those ridiculous like there's some
things you just can't eat
you just can't chew it down enough right
like you smell you'd be like yeah it's
coming up yeah but that didn't scare me
what scares me is like the bungee cords
under the helicopters type [ __ ] and I
was like how do you know that that's
gonna work out right every time I don't
know I know takes a bungee cord over
that look on the bull nuts and all that
stuff no really
yes to bull nuts or just just meat you
just eat it that's one of the easiest
ones bull nuts would be super easy
people love those things they call them
Rocky Mountain Oysters I've heard that
I've seen it uh one of those cooking
shows and they fry them home and look
like they look like fried pork rinds and
just yeah when was that we do with them
like yeah it looks like pork rinds they
slice it and fry it up hard oh wow I
hadn't seen that I'd seen sauteed and
I'd see that were they breaded them they
like breaded bull nuts ready to them and
fried them yeah it's apparently people
love them there they are
he's chopped those up rocky fried
cauliflower yeah man's deuce that's
cauliflower you eat it or they say it's
calamari you eat it and then your
friends like no I'm kidding it was bull
nuts see really bothers you that it's
bull nuts yeah kind of doesn't bother me
at all I think in if you're gonna eat
the whole animal you might as well use
balls to just how to respect